[Music]
we saw the paw patrol saved the
community of Adventure Bay many times
and now we should get prepared to see
them save our own world with these
real-life characters just wait until you
see the cute little Marshall working as
a firefighter if you love puppies as
much as we do don't forget to like this
video and subscribe for more today we
are showing you ten paw patrol dogs in
real life chase this dog works as a
police and traffic cop dog and even got
a job as a spy since season two when an
emergency happens he wants to direct
traffic so everyone can safely go home
and the other pups can take care of
those who need help chase can also track
missing animals or people with his spy
gear and bring them back to safety he is
a natural leader and takes missions
seriously but he has to pay attention to
cats and feathers because he's allergic
chase also knows how to have fun when
he's not working and playfully compete
with his best friend Marshall but what
does he look like in real life chase is
a German Shepherd puppy and he always
wears a deep blue outfit with a police
hat this breed is known for being very
obedient just like chase this is why
they often work as a guide dog for the
disabled a protective guard dog a search
rescue unit dog or a service dog for the
police k-9 now we understand why this
paw patrol dog takes his job seriously
the German Shepherds are also very
strong and courageous just like chase
but that doesn't mean they can't have
fun when they're not working they are
very loyal and loving so we bet these
dogs like to spend a lot of time with
their families rubble this member of the
paw Patrol is always there to help with
construction related work if a building
is damaged or if a train track doesn't
work properly he will be there to fix it
the youngest member of the group is
really playful he loves to do all sorts
of things except maybe coming
face-to-face with a spider but that
doesn't stop him from getting dirty to
do his job then he jumps in a bath when
he sees that he accomplished his mission
rubble also knows everything about
skateboards and snowboards but even if
this puppy looks rough he is completely
the opposite
he even tends to be emotional sometimes
and loves to take care of little animals
do you think that the real-life rubble
will be as soft as he is in the cartoon
when we look at these pretty
we know he is the construction pup of
the paw patrol is an English bulldog and
once again we never see him without his
yellow hard hat and his collar even if
this dog can look intimidating because
he is wide and muscular he is actually
friendly and docile just like rubble
Bulldogs are really playful and always
try to seek people out for attention
there is nothing that they enjoy more
than taking a nap with their owner but
this time we know that rubble is much
more active than that when he has to
work Everest
here comes the lady who can say that the
cold never bothered her anyway
she may not be a frozen queen but she
was really strong and independent just
like her we had the chance to meet
Everest the snowy mountain pup in season
two she saved Jake from falling off a
snow clip and quickly became a member of
the paw patrol when there's an emergency
she is always there to clear snow from
the roads Everest can use her grappling
hook to get from place to place
she's always enthusiastic and
hyperactive which helps her performing
rescues but what she loves the most is
probably her best friend Jake as she
hugs and licks him a lot and we think
that a real-life husky perfectly
represents her not only because they are
both adorable but also because they have
the same personality the Husky is really
alert and intelligent just like Everest
was when we first saw her this is also
what makes them great companions when we
want to spend time outside during the
winter and even if ever us can handle
the cold she also has a warm heart
Huskies are known to be really friendly
gentle and outgoing they are
affectionate with their family and
incredibly kid-friendly dogs now we
understand why everyone loves the snowy
mountain pups so much rocky when the
other pups are there to save people and
animals rocky is here to save the
environment the recycling pup always has
something to solve all the problems and
he doesn't have to buy these gadgets at
the most high-tech store he just picks
up pieces that could be recycled and
uses them to create something better
there is no limit to the number of ideas
Rocky can have and the number of tools
inside his pup pack however he might not
be the best eco puppy to protect the
ocean because he has a fear of water but
that doesn't stop him from accomplishing
his mission when he has something really
important to do is the real-life pup
afraid of water too when we see his fur
we think that this one must love to take
a lot of baths
this great Pomeranian is really
intelligent just like Rocky always knows
the smartest choice is saving the planet
before it's too late
they are also both active and
extroverted which gives them the chance
to meet other dogs and tell them what
they can do to protect the environment
however we think that this Pomeranian
might not be into recycling he just
loves to make sure that we don't waste
any food by eating everything he finds
and as long as everyone makes an effort
we think that we're going to be able to
change the world for the best tracker
just because you are small doesn't mean
you can't achieve great things we got
the chance to meet this dog in season 3
making him the 8th paw patrol pup
tracker loves playing outside and
discovering the wildlife this is why the
best place for him to live is in the
jungle away from the city he developed
amazing hearing skills that he now uses
to see if someone is in danger
even if his ears work perfectly tracker
doesn't trust his eyes as he is always
afraid to go in dark places but no
matter what this little dog is really
brave and will be able to face his fears
when he has to and this is one of the
characteristics that he shares with the
real-life Chihuahua they are both really
courageous
quick and alert this tiny dog often
barks before a stranger knocks at the
door of their home because he heard them
coming this is what surprisingly makes
him one of the best watch dogs
recommended by experts so these two pups
both have the same special skill we
can't believe how much energy is hidden
in this lively little dog for him there
is nothing better than being close to
people and spending time with his family
and we have no problem with that as we
would like to see tracker more often
Zuma here comes the water rescuer of the
paw patrol Zuma loves anything related
to water he is always there to rescue
sea animals with his speedboat when
there is an underwater emergency and
even when he is not working Zuma has a
lot of energy to spend living in a
boathouse he loves to dive into action
and go surfing another fun thing we like
about him is that he can't pronounce his
r correctly but laughter is the best
medicine for that and he knows it
nothing can stop this pup who is always
ready for adventure unfortunately his
services are not often required so we
don't get the chance to see him a lot
this is why we hope that this real-life
Cup will get more time on screen this
cute chocolate Labrador is already
wearing his orange water helmet and his
collar because he is ready for a new
mission
if you ever owned a Labrador you know
that this outgoing and agile dog loves
to play in the water and the mud this
means that they often get dirty and have
to take a lot of baths Zuma is laid-back
and very calm so he is really different
from most Labradors but no matter what
they are both kind gentle and trusting
this is what makes them the best family
members no matter how old you are
sweetie
this little puppy seems too precious to
be part of the paw patrol but don't
underestimate her the real reason why
she can't be part of the team is that
she is a villain the pet of the princess
of barking burg attempted to take over
the world
sweetie fakes being nice when she was
around the princess but she is actually
very sneaky she is not afraid of the paw
patrol which makes her really
intimidating even when her plans fail
and that she is punished
she puts the blame on other animals
sweetie isn't shy to use her cuteness to
get what she wants and we think that we
wouldn't be able to resist when we see
her beautiful eyes this is why we are
happy to know that the real-life sweetie
is actually really nice this west
highland white terrier is really cute
both on the outside and on the inside
this dog is really courageous active and
alert these are all the characteristics
you need to be part of the paw patrol
even though this dog is independent she
is also very friendly with her family so
you have nothing to fear if you ever see
a west highland white terrier we would
love to see a live action TV show with a
nice sweetie maybe she could even become
a hero to Apollo
here comes the super pup this is not a
dog like any other Apollo has the
ability to fly we don't get the chance
to see him a lot with the paw patrol but
he inspires everyone when they see him
on TV or in comic books rubble is one of
his biggest fans and can even be seen
dressed up like him with his blue mask
yellow uniform and red cape even if he
seems invincible the paw patrol one day
had to save Apollo and the bunnies from
the spider King this was the proof that
no one should be ashamed of asking for
help being together is what makes you
stronger unfortunately we haven't been
able to find a real-life puppy who can
fly but the super power of this American
white shepherd puppy is probably being
extremely cute these dogs have a high
level of self-confidence and are really
courageous
which explains why Apollo is always
there to save the
world the American Shepards are also
really alert fearless and eager which
are three important characteristics you
need to have to be a superhero
however these dogs are a little aloof so
don't take it personally if they like
spending time alone and don't have a lot
of friends they just love people in a
different way by making sure that they
are safe
just like Apollo does Skye she was the
favorite character of many little girls
until Everest joined the paw patrol team
Skye was the first female member of the
group and was always there to keep an
eye on the emergencies from above using
her pink helicopter
she also had a grappling hook to
transport people to safer places Skye is
always fun to watch as no matter what
she does she does a graceful backflip
with a smile on her face she also loves
to play and participate in activities
with her friends however she can become
a little emotional mostly when an eagle
is around but she always achieves her
goal no matter what happens
Skye is what we call a cockapoo a cocker
spaniel and poodle mix it is one of the
first designer dogs meeting that it is
not a pure breed dog just like the paw
patrol pup this dog is very outgoing
loving and friendly the kakapo can never
have too many friends and every
adventure is a new opportunity to have
fun this is why this breed is one of the
reasons why dogs are man's best friends
this kakapo is also very intelligent so
we understand where Skype excellent
memorization skills come from this smart
pup is probably one of our favorite
characters and we would love to fly with
her on her helicopter Marshall last but
not least here comes Marshall the fire
pup he is always there to check for
fires and extinguish them if necessary
he can also use his ladder if a kitten
is stuck in a tree and if someone ever
gets hurt they will be happy to hear
that Marshall is also a medic pup he
uses x-rays to make sure that no one has
any broken bones but seems to love
bandages a little too much he is
probably the funniest of them all as he
is silly and very clumsy he often gets
too excited and ends up saying that he
is okay after making a little mistake
but this is also what makes us laugh so
much
so we forgive him every time you have
probably seen a Dalmatian working with
firefighters before just like this
little boy Marshalls clumsiness could be
explained by the fact that Dalmatians
are really energetic playful and active
with so much energy we understand
why they can get a little too excited
sometimes but they are also very
intelligent and athletic which explains
why they can work as firehouse dogs they
are not only there to save people but
also to make the courageous firefighters
smile when they are on a break
these pups are always there to save the
world one smile at a time and that's it
for 10 paw patrol dogs in real life
don't forget to tell us in the comment
section down below who is your favorite
character thanks for watching
[Music]